hallo leute heute möchten wir euch
einige vokabeln und sätze für
restaurantbesuche vorstellen was sagt
man so im restaurant wie bestellt man
etwas und wie äußert man sonderwünsche
fiona feierabend ist gerade im
restaurant angekommen los geht's
hallo möchten sie schon bestellen da
waren sie noch auf jemanden
hallo im moment ich guck mal mein freund
ist
okay so nie mein freund der kommt doch
nicht erst fitness ins land so machtvoll
bis sie der profi zu tun und dafür
setzen wir uns nie wirklich nie leben
ist es total wichtig immer also unsere
dates und so das war wichtig aber ich
verstehe wenn bis sie ist der kann ich
ins restaurant gehen und sich den bauch
vollschlagen als fitness
und naja ich habe gehört dass auch voll
in nietheim und so
hört mal alleine essen naja egal ich
würde meine karte gucken haben sie eine
vegetarische karte
ja wir haben eine karte mit
vegetarischen und veganen gerichten
mega cool also vegan wenn ich jetzt
nicht da soll man dann schon ab essen
ich würde mich schon als vegetarierin
beschreiben man soll aber auch flexibel
bleiben habe ich gehört also flexibel
ist immer gut und was kommt schon an
[Musik]
flexitarier dann vielleicht
okay ich hol schon mal die karte möchten
sie denn schon was zu trinken bestellen
er ja gerne ich hätte gerne an wasser
mit zitrone
mit oder ohne
mit oder ohne was
mit oder ohne kohlensäure
mit natürlich also schon sprudeln also
wasser aus dem hahn
also gerne sprudel mit eiswürfeln und 2
und dann hatte ich dazu gerne noch ein
glas rotwein einen trockenen ein glas
rotwein am tag ist nämlich gesund gerne
da hatten wir einen spätburgunder einen
merlot und eine woche anzubieten welchen
hätten sie denn gerne
bringen sie mal ein paar den den sie am
besten finden
ok bis gleich
wenn ihr jetzt noch weiter deutsch
lernen möchte dann werdet mitglied von
easy germany bekommt uns mit jedem video
ein workshop mit vokabel listen und
interaktiven übungen wir freuen uns wenn
ihr teil unserer community werdet
guten tag hier ist die karte
und hier das wasser
das denn
was ist von den fuß sind spiralen oder
in form einer eh nix üblicherweise circa
4 cm lang und werden außerdem so hier
ein trockener spätburgunder
ich hoffe der schmeckt ihnen
denken
ach so ja
roth war nach lecker rote ein
gut danke gut haben sie sich entschieden
was kann ich ihnen bringen oh
ja ich hätte gerne den lachs auf
lilly mit saisonalem gemüse ich habe
mich heute für
italien schieben
wechsel bleiben der lachs da kommt aber
auch schon aus der region
naja sie befinden sich in berlin also so
ganz aus der region kommt der dax nun
nicht
stimmt august hauptsache es schmeckt
pommes mit ketchup und mayo
natürlich wie wünschen
ganz ehrlich wenn du das noch einmal
machst dann ist es vorbei ich sag's dir
vorbei ich sitze an einem restaurant ist
es super peinlich ich würde mich nach
hause gehe ich könnte losheulen aber ja
also wenn du was besseres zu tun das ist
auch okay aber nächstes mal echt
erlassen
guten appetit nudeln
versteckt hielt
hat es ihnen geschmeckt
das war schon ganz gut na ist noch dabei
ein rabbi für meine story sport zu
machen ich bin informationen und na ja
also ich muss schon sagen die profis
hätten etwas größer sein können und der
lachs war so mittel muss ich lange
warten haben ok es tut mir leid ich
werde es weiter geben
[Musik]
ich habe gehört dass sie nicht ganz
zufrieden waren das tut mir leid der
spätburgunder geht heute auf uns wären
dann noch 19 eur 50
m
vielen dank
[Musik]
dann mit dem fuß an
vielen dank dann wünsche ich ihnen noch
einen schönen tag
[Musik]
wir hoffen ihr habt heute einige
vokabeln und sätze für euren nächsten
restaurantbesuch gelernt hattet ihr
schon einmal lustige oder komische
situation im restaurant habt ihr
vielleicht etwas bestellt und etwas
völlig anderes bekommen zeit eure
geschichten in den kommentaren und wir
freuen uns sehr wenn ihr unsere arbeit
unterstützt indem ein mitglied von the
german werdet dann könnt ihr mit unseren
vielen lernmaterialien noch intensiver
deutsch lernen bis bald
[Musik]
der fleiß ist
es tut mir leid